[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand je marche dans la rue
j'entends les âmes qui ont eu
regardez cette femme qu'elle a lu
c'est une femme comme on en voit plus
[Musique]
me connaître
la source
avec moi
pour dormir dans mes bras ne m'appelez
pas
[Musique]
je suis
pas
si mon cœur
je suis un tra
[Musique]
bonjour
dormir dans mes bras de ma vie pas
[Musique]
non je suis
je suis un travesti de notre
casque
[Musique]
de mon cul
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis sûr que vous voulez je suis sûr
que vous
[Musique]
dire ce que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va mais franchement c'est incroyable
vraiment tu nous as fait kiffer
à Paris tu peux me tutoyer
on est à Paris
[Applaudissements]